no what that's
tight and it has the
tissue they took us
[Music]
seriously all right guys um so I was
watching this mini documentary about
it's on OTR food and history the
documentary is called exploring
Southeast Asia's most unappreciated
Cuisine oh n was just watching that what
does it l sh for was watching this you
think it's laan food well cuz Uncle
Roger was recently saying laan food is
[__] I wish it was laan food okay just
complete he says it's like the wannabe
Thai food it's a [__] and then everyone
got so mad you don't know [__] about
[__] L food it's [__] so different
but to be honest though after that here
we go it actually benefited La food
because I started eating I went
specifically to Lan restaurants to see
the difference so it benefited L food
because you went to a couple restaurants
it's a great big honor for L it's a big
big mve Big mve Y Jo takawa has tried it
three restaurants in he loves it can't
confirm at this I was convinced Stella
reviews Uncle Roger you're wrong you
liked it I love or I mean I already had
it before but I had to have like but I
had to have specific laan dishes to
compare like they got some crispy rice
they got this like soup that's like L
and udon and I know they're going to
hate me cuz they're like it's not on
it's our own thing but like it's
literally laan UD on it's got thick
noodles it's [__] B so what do you
think is the most unappreciated cuisine
in Southeast Asia I don't know Southeast
Asian Cuisines I think are so good but
it's not mainstream cuz like it's just
recently that you see more Malaysian
restaurants coming out that's true um
people are venturing outside of Thai
food and you know like yeah I think
there's not enough of of like
restaurants for people to try yeah you
know what I never tried Guamanian food
but that ain't Southeast Asian though
that's not what is Guamanian it's
Polynesian
gu they got Guamanian barbecue oh how is
that different what do they put on
it some Guam
sauce more can't beat them you can't
stop this hit it with the Guam
sauce well he's got deep cultural
knowledge so um I was watching this
video and it's I think it's called
chamaro
oh oh that looks good it does look good
but it's
underappreciated okay what yell seen
that before Filipino food all right you
guys ready for this so this is in the
middle of the documentary and then Steve
just gets it in a trash can and throws
it away it's about it's about 14 minutes
in no one so much is despised despised
that might be we can't tell this story
without confronting that subject so it's
Filipino food they're talking about how
it's the most
hated what no oh my God what no what
that's
tight has the
tissue they took us
seriously aome they believe my God
that's amazing that is amazing that's
incredible that made my whole day after
that clip it's nothing about white
people [__] on Filipino food that
made my whole day that is so [__]
funny I like it's said trash in the text
trash hey who would you like to than out
there dude trolling to the Moon by the
way trolling to the Moon we made it it's
going to the Moon wow that's wild dude
so I was at Christmas I was it Christmas
and I was telling my father uh in-law
about this bit about how I [__] hate
Filipino food and [__] and he was crying
he couldn't even breathe he was laughing
so hard he couldn't even
breathe Y show them this documentary
dude show them this I know right he'll
love it he'll love it I can't believe
they took it seriously they really took
it seriously I can believe it took it
Ser really no but when Steve said i' go
to uh Filipino Buffet so I could load up
the plate just to throw it away he
[__] sold it D what a [__] just so I
could throw it away I still think about
that [__] today dude it's even weirder
because they're they're using it as an
element to support a narrative that I
didn't even know existed honestly I
didn't know that like most people hate
Philip I think Steve started the
narrative no can we go back to my
[__] outfit how could you take this
guy seriously and then cut to the guy
with the nose
bleed dude I have to explain I have to
explain myself every time I get in and
out of a uber car every time I go to my
hotel I have to explain to myself this
dude I mean they I like how you're the
poster boy of a intolerant white guy I
love it they jump off part two which is
called why does the world hate philippin
the world hat using the image of Steve
like in his freaking tracksuit or in his
woot chain that's one of my track the
short version is it's pretty the trash
where it belongs but then it's followed
with clips of people actually not liking
it all white guys yeah all white dudes
how can you not like it it's one of the
easiest foods to Steve he hates it yeah
I hate it real bad real bad he use this
C too was it was it an actual stereotype
like yeah yeah I never heard of that I
didn't hear about that either I didn't
that's why it's even funnier because I
didn't know it was a thing and it we
just played into it I honestly had I
really had no idea I really think Steve
C was the Catalyst for the momentum to
build this discrimination against I made
it okay people were a lot of white
people out there were like I don't know
if I can say that yeah they didn't want
to get canceled and they were like yo
this savior right over here here could
speak up for us I do feel like I hear I
do hear this narrative with people that
like don't really know that many
Filipino folks that don't have like a
close group of family friends you know I
do I have heard people say like I hate
Filipino food yeah definitely what is
there to hate there's so many things in
Philipino well it's usually it's usually
something like I went to a a family and
I'm like they had like one thing they
didn't like and they're like oh Filipino
food is a g i mean if you're eating
honestly the more legit Filipino food
gets the more intimidating it is but
then like if when I went to Australia we
went to like a like like just a normal
like uh Food Fest area and there was
tons of Filipino food more than here
Australia is different though cuz they
have like their influence on Southeast
uh Southeast Asian food is like way
higher and they had the longest lines
and it was just like chicken skewers
beef skewers it's like yeah what is that
dish that looks so good the thing in a
skillet had a lemon like a half chopped
lemon in there yeah the first thing you
had the video Frozen on it when we that
look like a be steak fried rice almost
before they show part two yeah you
probably [__] sitting here too
loading this thing up the little shitty
didn't gr on your face you know it's
going to show me in a sec that's why I
was cracking up earlier cuz I saw him
put that title in the thing and I was
like that's you're talking about that
thing yeah yeah yeah what is that oh no
man that looks good that looks bomb you
know what I haven't tried yet I ate a
lot of Filipino food but I haven't tried
the uh the spread where they put out the
banana leaves and then you just have
[__] barbecue yeah
R just sit there and just [__] Feast
like it's a crab boil I want to do that
that does look really funion are really
yeah cuz after I found this video like
then my algorithm started showing me
other videos of people talking about the
same thing how like but that's
everything there's so many videos about
how people hate all kinds of foods out
there it's not like everyone knows
Filipino foods sucks nobody talks about
it with such poetry like talking about
going to a buff buff aland loading up
your PL just to dump it in the trash I
don't think anybody talk they might be
like it's a little salty or light on
this but you're like I load up my whole
[__] place so I dump it in the trash
which is funny like the degree that he's
saying it you would think someone would
be smart enough to be like okay yeah
that's this is stupid wild to me and
then people are like dude and this guy's
married to a
Filipino bro Steve will say some wild
[__] just because he's doing a bit but
the comments are they always think he's
they always think he's telling the
that's that's Ryan's fault cuz he's
always chopping out the context and just
hitting the punch line but that's what
we want that's what we want we want
people to like
morons he knows exactly what I like yeah
let's get more documentaries dude what
else what other Nation actually in a
documentary that's taught in um feminism
courses and then the documentary is
called tough guys 2 and everyone kept
sending it to me in college like the
sequel tough guys 2 yeah it's number two
it's not one but it's called tough guys
right and then they kept sending it to
me I was like what the [__] is this
basically they they have a u so their
their their hypothesis or their position
is that Asian-American men were adopting
Black Culture to appear more tough and
aggressive I'm like that statement is
hella [__] racist to begin with cuz
you're saying that Hip Hop and Black
Culture is aggressive age-old [__]
racist ideal right and on top of that
they're thinking that Asians are
mimicking like black people rather than
saying like they grew up in a black
neighborhood or whatever but what they
used to prove that point is I did a
character in a called Asians acting
black so I was pretending to be like a a
wannabe like rapper so I was like
speaking like that they took that fake
character and they said see look at
these Asians pretending to be black and
at the end of that video I go I make a
point right I'm just saying like yeah
everyone thinks certain Asians are
acting black but you guys are forgetting
that we grow up in black neighborhoods
too and that's where we learn English
and I kind of dissect it and I'm just
like that's [__] crazy so they
decided to cut out that portion to prove
a point by using a parody character
that's like using Matt TV and SNL to
prove a legitimate point or Babylon b or
onion that's so [__] crazy yeah but
that's being show you gave him really
good reference material though you know
what I mean it's probably just like they
just they just had better traction you
know this is you're being lazy as [__]
right but that's that's showed in
schools so people are watching that in
school funny funny I prefer that and I'm
like that's [__] tough guys 2 we got
to get this DVD bro can you sue can you
sue for tough guys three like what's up
you know they didn't make any money on
tough guys too [__] out here I asked my
lawyer to to to to get a a you know a
whole like what do you call it like a
copyright infringement but he said it it
fell under fair use so even if it's used
incorrectly I think the only best way is
maybe what we should do is take that
material and dissect it and like
ridicule it because like I I just can't
believe they're teaching that in
University let's [__] on Tough Guys
University you're supposed to check your
sources make sure it's credible Let's
Just Produce tough guys 3 I'm in let
just make it let's just get the rights
to the title and just make it are you
looking to be a more masculine
male we kill this maybe let maybe
somebody uh somebody in that production
crew knew you from back in the day he
goes oh he's not acting that guy's not
acting that's so funny he's scary he's
like that that's your mama I had to
figure out who the [__] made this right
it's some Canadian guy so I'm like he's
looking at it from a Canadian lens he's
probably like oh in Canada you have all
these new Asian immigrants that are
probably adop in Hip Hop so he sees it
from that lens he doesn't see it from
like oh these kids grow up in America in
different neighborhoods they're not
acting a certain way you know what I
mean maybe maybe he's an Asian in Canada
who's [__] sick and tired of being
called White adjacent oh so he's
producing this [__] thing by by
bringing and Bridging the Gap between
Asians and blacks and I think I think
that's why we should produce tough guys
three we should we should carry on that
mantle I think DRS the link dude tough
guys three tough guys three I'm in is it
tff please tell me it's tff no it's
tough but the guy is g u i s it's like
disguise yeah oh tough guys oh that's
sick
so cool oh my God yo stupid anon's hyp
dude look how happy Anthony is I would
actually like to debate this guy because
disgu disguise yeah dis if you're
supposed to be like I don't know man I
feel I feel like this guy doesn't have a
backbone toate if you're if you're a
professor right and then you have a you
have this point you should be able to
debate like what you know and and he
clearly didn't he's from Canada his life
already sucks I feel like he's missing
the social aspect if he can't if read
the Sati that I don't think he's going
to [__] have it I don't think he's
going to have it like how can you use
satirical things as as proof to
supporting your time bro that's all
people do that's like [__] quoting a
like a a porn
video it's like look how people are
having sex and it cuts to [__] your
psychology Pap porn like what the it's
like sometimes at jobs men use leverage
in order to have sex with women and he's
like hey so like um you know you late on
your work uh we're going have to figure
something out fure have to blow
me you're probably going to have to suck
my dick and lick lick my butthole too oh
no I guess I have to can you believe the
guy just recorded and didn't help like
what the [__] dude landlords are
predatory I mean all we did was discover
the hack in that industry that's
all I yeah I haven't seen the whole
documentary press the link and buo for
the GoFundMe for tough guys 3 Let's Go y
[Music]
e